we know now that you will in this in the
semi-finals be playing ninjat abasov did
you get a chance to see his game today
and what are your thoughts on that match
up
I only saw the opening which looked
fairly um
fairly innocuous
um
and then I saw that he won
I don't really know know how but
um he's having a fantastic tournament
look at the
the confidence with which he plays with
um is
is astounding and also just yeah the
level of um opponents that he's knocked
out is
um it's very yeah it's very impressive
so it won't be um won't be easy for sure
and also like he has a candidate spot
now so
he's basically playing with um literally
house house money now so
yes you have mentioned it and we have a
question from the audience from kazuya
Mishima will you play the candidates if
you qualify can you reveal us something
here
um
no I mean under I would say under the
current format there is
absolutely no no chance so I think
everybody should just operate under the
assumption that I will not play
the candidates and that everybody else
who's in the semi-final is qualified for
the candidates
okay big announcement breaking news you
heard it here first
um yeah so 69th seed avasoff potentially
in the candidates